[Music]
once again there was some news about the
marvel cinematic universe this week
first there's the third solo film of the
ant-man series which is not expected to
be released before summer
2022. we're talking about rapper and
actor t.i who embodied the burglar dave
and ant-man the reason for his abrupt
departure is an ongoing court case
according to which the 40 year old is
accused of sexual abuse
assault kidnapping and many other
offenses
so it's no wonder that the entire
ant-man team is keeping its distance and
cancelling the role
especially since disney is in no way
known for giving problematic
personalities a stage
instead there's much more pleasant news
about the shooting of thor
love and thunder because as new
snapshots from the said reveal
director taika waititi will pick up on
the well-known theatrical gag from thor
ragnarok
then this the scene in which nameless
asgardian actors perform a play in which
the supposed demise of loki is
re-enacted
upon closer inspection it quickly
becomes apparent that matt damon
sam neil and chris hemsworth brother
luke among others make a brief
appearance
new to the cast will apparently be
melissa mccarthy who will likely play
this stage counterpart to loki sistahila
this is not a groundbreaking story
revelation but it's nice to see that
white titi is sticking to the funny
cameo appearances in the upcoming thor
movie
last but not least actress lupita
nyong'o expressed her views on the
upcoming mcu adventure black panther
ii despite the tragic passing of her
acting colleague chadwick boseman last
year
the 30 year old actress is optimistic
about the future during an appearance on
good morning america
she said that great care is being taken
by everyone to treat bozeman's legacy
and his well-known role as king with
dignity
the black panther team is doing
everything they can to continue the role
in some way and
director ryan coogler is said to have
some very exciting ideas already
we will probably only find out exactly
what this means when the movie is
released on july 8th
2022 a couple of days ago the news that
a new superman movies in the works
wasn't met with enthusiasm among all
fans
the main reason for this is that henry
cavill who is very popular with fans
will no longer play a role in the film
the main character clark kent who he
embodied will presumably not be featured
in the film either
because jj abram's latest project is
apparently a reboot with a new story
rumor has it that the comic book story
about the african-american superman
calvin ellis could serve as the
inspiration for the movie
abram says he's looking forward to a new
powerful and also touching superman
story which he and screenwriter tenaci
coates will bring to the big screen
also warner chairman toby emerick is
convinced that the between the world and
me author has the potential to give fans
a new and exciting take on superman
given code's previous works which have
been deeply critical of society it seems
likely that we will soon see the first
african-american superman and a full
adoption what do you think
is the superman series really need to
get revamped with a new league character
or would you rather have seen a sequel
with clark kent and the henry cavill
drop us a comment down below and
let us know neil bloom ambitious sci-fi
film district 9 was released in theaters
in 2009
bloom cam's own project the short film
alive in joburg which was released in
2005
served as the template for this
uncompromising blockbuster in video game
aesthetics with a budget of 30 million
us dollars the film draws the phenomenal
211 million us dollars worldwide and is
still one of the few examples that have
downright revolutionized the science
fiction genre
as the south african director announced
on twitter a few days ago
work on this sequel district 10 is
already underway and is being panned
jointly by himself
charity copley and terry tatchell
kopleyjumbodied the main role of wikis
in district 9 thus returns to the sequel
to his then screen debut nevertheless we
shouldn't expect to release anytime soon
because bloomkamp is known for working
on several projects
at the same time and the slightly
neglecting some of his films
no matter what we are looking forward to
district 10 and will keep you up to date
with the latest
news so feel free to subscribe and look
forward to exciting news about movies in
series now
and in the future in the night from
february 28 to march 1st the annual gold
globe awards of the hollywood foreign
press took once again plays in los
angeles the event hosted by tina frey
and amy polo wasn't able to surprise
riley because this year
netflix is again at the top of the
winners list with its countless own
productions
in the best drama series category for
instance netflix's own production
the crown managed to stand up to
disney's the mandalorian which is also
extremely popular miniseries the queen's
gambit and actress emma koran jillian
anderson and anya taylor joy along with
fellow actor josh o'connor also claimed
the number of awards for the streaming
giant
cementing its position of power in the
serious field
as far as movies are concerned nomadland
won best drama and borrowed 2-1 best
comedy
both sharing their victory in the top 2
movie categories while the late black
panther star chadwick boseman
was posthumously awarded best actor in a
drama
for his role in marines black bottom the
female equivalent was claimed by fellow
actress
andra day for her role in the united
states versus billie holiday
as deadline recently reported hollywood
stars hugh grant and sapphila lilies
will join the cast of paramounts
dungeons and dragons adaption the 60
year old bridge is expected to take on
the role of the antagonist while his
only
19 year old colleague who made her mark
in projects including annie musgetty's
two it movies will play in as yet
unnamed role
both will be inevitably in front of the
camera with protagonist chris pine who
has been revealed for quite some time
currently
nothing is known about the content but
the film will most likely be set in the
typical dungeons and dragon setting full
of orcs dragons
and magic jonathan goldstein and jon
francis daily
were appointed as directors a while ago
and the script is also said to have been
written by the two of them
believing the rumors the film revolves
around an adventurer who together with
his mystical companions
wants to find a well-hidden treasure
still these are only
wild speculations and we will have to
wait a little longer before we get
any official information the expected
release date of the dungeons and dragons
film adaption
is may 27 2022
pleasant news for all fans of the
monsterverse
a few days ago not only was there new
footage from godzilla versus kong but
the potential running time of the film
was
also leaked according to the french
website aloe sin
godzilla vs kong is expected to run for
1 hour and 53 minutes
which would make it not only the
shortest godzilla movie but also the
shortest monster burst movie
outright although legendary
entertainment has not yet made a
statement on the matter
the new approach would make perfect
sense since the previous movies have
always had to put up with the complaint
of being
longer than necessary speaking of longer
in an interview with screenrant film
composer and youtuber junkyxl reveal
another exciting detail
he stated that one of the fight scenes
between the two giants will last a
whooping
18 minutes those who have already seen
the first trailer will know which scene
is meant
namely the one in which godzilla sneaks
up on one of the aircraft carriers to
attack
kong it will be exciting in any case
because godzilla vs kong will be
released on march
31st in the us both in theaters and on
hbo max
you